Toronto's Mayor John Tory is resigning
he said so on Friday after it became
public he had an affair with an employee
but he's not leaving just yet Toronto is
in the midst of budget deliberations and
Tori wants to see that through Global's
Matthew Bingley is at Toronto City Hall
tonight Matthew
Donna when Toronto's mayor appeared late
Friday to announce that he was resigning
he avoided using two key words effective
immediately and now we've learned that
Tori will stick around to see his budget
through
the office of Toronto's mayor is no
stranger to a gaggle of reporters
waiting outside but the John Tory era
was able to avoid it until now I
developed a relationship with an
employee in my office in a way that did
not meet the standards to which I hold
myself as mayor and as a family man
Tori's admission to an affair with a
staffer in his office came with a
guarantee his time is Mayor would end
early but he offered no timing on when
that will happen complicating when an
upcoming by-election will take place the
only way that a member can step down and
resign is to actually file written
notice with the clerk don't believe
that's happened once that happens then
the clerk must put the uh the
resignation at the next council meeting
as counselors carried on meetings with
the mayor some were Keen to see a
reversal of the resignation we just got
to make sure that we give Assurance to
the public that it's a time of stability
that coming together and uh and look
he's done a lot of great things for the
city and he can make a graceful exit
this Wednesday Council will have to
approve a budget which under new
provincial legislation and its strong
mayor Powers is officially the Tory
budget I don't think you should stick
around I think basically he said he's
resigned and it just complicates things
the mayor's office says Tori has held
meetings with senior leadership to
discuss an orderly transition of power
the timing of which won't be revealed
until after that budget meeting another
complicating Factor are those strong
mayor Powers which can't be transferred
to the deputy mayor and will create
difficulty for future city business
City council's budget meeting was always
bound to be a contentious one as the
mayor's Rivals attempted to make changes
to it now with the guarantee that John
Tory will actually be there this meeting
will take on an entirely different tone
Donna okay Matthew Bingley at Toronto
City Hall thanks